how's this for a green energy scam the
Biden Administration is classifying some
of the country's most elite and
exclusive locals as lowincome areas so
they can get EV tax credits the wealthy
enclaves range from Barack Obama's
favorite vacation spot of Martha's
Vineyard to Joe Biden's Beach House
community of rith Beach Delaware where
he keeps the Corvette among other things
speaking of the big guy Biden was just
bragging about electric buses that have
been breaking down in cities across the
country and so we're going from this uh
to this who we received uh funds from
your Administration $21 million to
purchase electric buses and so we are on
our way to having a low to no emission
uh Transit Fleet in the city of tucon if
you want to get a job don't give it to a
May uh it's like story time at the home
and his Energy Secretary Jennifer grome
seems to be in denial as more car
companies pull the plug PL on electric
cars this movement toward
electrification I think is inexorable it
is happening CEOs will tell you they're
not pulling back or reversing Trend in
their Investments they may be slowing a
little bit but honestly uh I I think
this is only it's a snowball that's
going downhill that is only going to
accelerate faster than an EV car Jesse
uh why would they choose Martha's
Vineyard is it so the help can get to
the Estates of the Rich and Power power
ful is this like something selfish
disguised as climate and compassion well
I mean if they can reclassify a man as a
woman they can reclassify the vineyard
as the projects they can do whatever
they want Greg it's just words you know
the average price of a house is $2.3
million in Martha's Vineyard I don't
think Barack Obama would move to a
lowincome neighborhood same with Monto
there's like Calvin Klein some of Judge
Janine's wealthy friends out there I
mean no one really is going there
without a so John KY I think Spike Lee
all have homes here no one in a
lowincome situation needs an EV plugin
have you seen Johnny go to the projects
Johnny Goes to the project he say Joe
Biden has just given this neighborhood
30 million dollar and everyone goes yeah
and they what do you need and they go we
need new this we need that and J goes
sorry you're getting an electric car
plug in and they go what
the no one wants this stuff yeah it's
true why would they do this is it
because they figure that that that
neighborhood would be amenable to it so
these are they're looking for the early
adopters right because and and with any
new techn technology it takes an early
adopter to be like comfortable with all
the discomforts of it and the
frustrations but for these people it's
their third or fourth car right and they
cost $60,000 they don't care so that you
can afford to have something like this
at the beach or on the vineyard because
you took your private plane to get there
mhm that is true Richard it
it's not a replacement for anything for
the rich and Powerful it's an adjunct is
that the right term an addition yeah an
addition listen I I I I tend to agree
with that I but I think Dana makes a
point right I think part of it is
getting to early adapters I think the
other part right and when you look at
the policy and you talk to some of the
folks in the Biden Administration they
would say to you we're trying to create
a nation a network of power charging
stations so you can drive from
California to New York City without have
to be Richard it's an Island WA is yeah
but nuck is also hold on a minute hold
on a minute you just need a bike let me
but listen I'm going to be the explainer
and chief here for just a second if you
look at the US Census Data Nantucket and
monok are considered rural communities
right that's I'm not I'm not lying to
you this is exactly what the Census Data
says so the ideal is we need to put
rural charg we need to put charging
stations in rural communities whether
it's in Mississippi or it's in New York
are there any there should be some I'm
not tell I'm trying to take it seriously
but you listen go to the
the whole idea of putting these in
Martha's Vineyards I'm not I'm not
defending it I'm telling you what the
policy says right I I I I hear that I I
might tend to agree with you I'm telling
you what the policy is and isn't and I
think the goal is to try to create a na
Nationwide power charging system so you
can drive your expensive Tesla across
the country wait a minute wait I don't
know what the number I'm next I don't
know what the thank you I don't know
what the number is but we did this a
couple weeks ago where there was like7
billion dollar or something and they had
an installed One charging station this
administration's really on their game
and that loser the uh uh grandholm the
Energy Secretary this thing is going to
snowball is she kidding the first of all
the electric vehicle interest in one
year went down from 49% to 41% but among
Generation Z it went from 61 to 49% and
all this hogwash about putting it in
lowincome places Greenwich the average
price of a home is is 1.9 million okay
and what they're trying to do is if
they're trying to help lowincome people
they're not doing that because if they
were they'd put it in Chicago and
they're not doing that they're putting
it in Martha's Vineyard and Greenwich
because they're hoping that the rich
people will buy that car they're
speaking to their next uh audience of
who's going to buy the car so it's a
bunch of nonsense they're all full of it
and Ford production we did this a few
weeks ago they cut production of cars by
50% Herz slot something like a quarter
of a million or a half a million dollars
in rentals it's a nightmare hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else